Chris Hemsworth Tyler Ray kids and
probably once again on a perilous Rescue
Mission in Netflix's extraction 2. he's
proven he can save innocence and danger
but was he able to save himself this
time warning spoilers for extraction 2
ahead
after seemingly being killed at the end
of the previous movie it turns out that
Tyler survived his Fallen to the river
and eventually winds up in a Dubai
Hospital One Rehab Montage later and
he's back to his old self and ready to
roll his mission this time around is to
save his ex-wife's sister katavan and
her two children who have been
forcefully imprisoned by David a crime
Lord and the patriarch of their family
Tyler and his small team are able to get
the family out of the jail and kill
David in the process they soon end up
being hunted by David's brother zurab
who becomes obsessed with killing Tyler
although ketovan has no desire to return
to her old life her son Sandro is
conflicted about leaving the people he
considers his family
you think you saved me
that you're some hero
doesn't really matter what I think this
inner identity crisis leads sanjo to
give away the group's position with that
info Zoo Rob and his men ambushed
Tyler's team during all the Carnage that
confused Sandro decides to go with his
uncle but ultimately regrets it after
seeing how crazy some violent sarabas
become Tyler is reunited with his
ex-wife Mia and he's forced to recall
the painful memories tied to him not
being there when his son died from
lymphoma now after that brief and
emotional reunion Tyler heads out to
kill zurab once and for all and takes
Sandro out of this dangerous life for
good
when Tyler arrives to save Sandro to
kill zurabi has no issues taking down
all of zurab's remaining soldiers but
then he runs into a problem when he
confronts zurab in a church as who
rather strapped a bomb vest onto Sandro
and has the Detonator in his hand he's
ready to blow everything up if Tyler
makes a wrong move zuraba Sandro de Sam
Tyler and sassandra was shooting him in
the head Sandro refuses and zurab calls
him weak before pointing the gun towards
Tyler luckily for Tyler Nick shows up to
stop zurab from killing him and a huge
brawl eventually breaks out during the
big fight Nick is severely injured
Sandra manages to get the bomb vest off
of himself before he can go off that's
for zurab and Tyler after their fight
they find themselves on the floor
exhausted although Tyler has clearly won
the fight Zoo Rob says it will never
stop hunting and try to kill Tyler
so Tyler viciously shoots him in the
head Tyler is able to finally end the
cut and Mouse game and complete his
mission but it comes an unexpected cast
Tyler can't escape the consequences of
the Carnage and bloodshed he and his
team have left on their path he gets
sold off to prison where he's visited by
Mia she says that their son was actually
very proud of Tyler for what he did as a
soldier and was inspired by his bravery
his last image of you was a new walking
out on him
as you're going off to save people it's
an emotionally fulfilling moments that
enables Tyler to push past the grief and
guilt that's Afflicted him for so long
though he's regained some peace it seems
like the remainder of Tyler's life will
likely be in prison until the familiar
face comes to bust him out shortly after
talking with Mia Tyler is escorted out
of the prison and led to see the
mysterious man in the suit played by
Idris Elba who has a new mission for him
Tyler initially shows some hesitancy
about going back out in the field but
isn't given much of a choice at least
his request to reunite with his team is
fulfilled because Nick is shown to be
stepping out of an SUV Tyler is still
curious about the naughty person the man
in the suit actually works for but he
doesn't get that answer at least not yet
there are multiple conversations
throughout extraction too about defining
true family and what it means to be a
good father for Sandro he's constantly
conflicted about leaving behind his
uncle and the criminal organization his
father built because he's come to see
them as his family for his part Tyler's
self-resentment over leaving his El Son
and not being there until the end
although Tyler and Sandro rarely see eye
to eye they both come to the same
realization about family and fatherhood
they come to learn that family means
something much deeper than just physical
proximity sanjo starts to understand
that his uncle wants to keep him his mom
and his brother closer maintain power
not out of love he also comes to see how
Tyler and his mother are willing to
protect him at all costs and Tyler
begins to understand the real impact he
made as a father when Mia tells him
about how much he inspired his son
Tyler is able to regain his physical
strength to complete this Mission but
it's still not clear if he's really in
good shape to continue in the field his
Guild from not being around for his son
during his final moments still haunts
him and makes him feel broken it's a
yielding Devotion to rescuing catavan
and her children seems to be a sort of
penance not only is he willing to do
anything and everything to keep his
family safe even if it leads to his own
death but he even tells Mia to literally
take everything he has including a hefty
amount of security cash and give it to
catavan to support her family that said
when Tyler learns his decision to leave
during his son's final moments didn't
cause his son to hate him it creates a
real change within him this realization
is the last hurdle he needed to overcome
to really move forward on his own it
gives him a new Strength that means more
than any of the physical rebuilding he
did at the start of the film
extraction 2 ends in a far different
place than the first movie does Tyler
was by all indications dead at the end
of extraction but now he's not just
alive but being recruited with Nick for
a whole new Mission plus there's a
lingering question of just who the man
in the suits employer is something
audiences are sure to want to know my
name doesn't matter
no it does
who I work for well there isn't much to
go on in terms of Italian Nick could be
fighting against and with or where they
could be going it's almost assured that
the third film is on the way now that
Tyler has been able to move past his
guilt and grief surrounding his son's
death this is sort of the start of a new
chapter for him and the opportunity for
a new arc to begin although there hasn't
been any confirmation yet from Netflix
or anyone involved at the third
extraction filmers in development you
started to believe that the streamer
would pass on the opportunity to
continue this franchise there's also a
reason to wonder if extraction might
expand into a bigger franchise Beyond
just direct sequels the first film was a
humongous success for Netflix and
probably one of the most well-regarded
original films that come from the
streaming giant extraction 2 easily
shows potential to be just as big it's
essentially Netflix's equivalent to a
summer blockbuster so it's very much a
possibility that Netflix could have
plans to expand the franchise Beyond
Tyler's story there are a number of
interesting routes the franchise could
take in expanding the story and world of
extraction there could easily be
spin-off films or series of focus on
other agents and mercenary to tune the
man in the suit works or maybe even a
film where Nick goes on her own mission
maybe we could even get a prequel
focusing on Tyler's missions directly
after a sun died to see some of the
relationships he developed during that
rough time in his life in shorts Netflix
could extract a lot of content out of
this franchise
that's clear potential for a third
extraction film if not more but what do
the cast and crew think about there
being another entry in Tyler's story
director Sam Hargrave is certainly
optimistic in an interview with decider
he said there's definitely an appetite
for a third movie Hargrave added that
not only has Netflix expressed
excitement about her sequel the
production company behind the films has
discussed it and Chris Hemsworth quote
loves playing the character the director
even mentioned that he's got some ideas
what a third film could be but also
clarify that a sequel will likely only
happen if extraction 2 performs well on
Netflix it seems like Hargrave would
certainly be up for returning if
extraction 3 was given the green light
and Hemsworth seemed to share an
optimism in an interview with total film
magazine the actor was very excited to
talk about the extraction films and how
he'd love to come back for more he said
I loved playing the character I love
this world I love having something else
outside of Marvel that's a massive bit
of a following he even said that it
would be a shame if they didn't get the
chance to do more so it seems like the
big players of the extraction franchise
want to come back
although extraction 2 released it a few
years after its predecessor fans might
have to wait a little longer for the
franchise to return but maybe not for
the reasons people expect Hemsworth
recently announced that he was taking a
break from acting to spend more time
with his family after he discovered on
the National Geographic series Limitless
that he carries a gene connected to an
increased risk of Alzheimer's disease
however the actor has clarified that his
decision to take a break isn't just
about his health Discovery he taught
Entertainment Tonight I wondered I'd
come off because I'd been working for 10
years and I've got three kids that I
want to spend more time with given that
Hemsworth has been tirelessly portraying
Thor in the MCU and has had a solid
string of other roles over the last
decade it's not a huge surprise that it
wants to take a breather however his
acting break does leave the future of
the extraction franchise in question
maybe Hemsworth absence will allow the
franchise to expand and explore spin-off
stories in that world until Hemsworth
returns to acting and extraction 3 can
take off
foreign